How about we do a song just by hitting our microphones, right, like a, okay, ready? So I'm gonna, I'm gonna do, okay. I'm like a rhythm thing. Yeah, I'm gonna start a beat and then you guys fill it in. Sean's gonna go second and Willie's gonna go third. Here we go. Okay. I'm really cheesing myself out.
我们只用敲击麦克风来做一首歌怎么样？就像，好吧，准备好了吗？所以我要，我要做，好吧。就像打节奏一样。对，我先起个节奏，然后你们来接上。肖恩第二个上，威利第三个。我们开始吧。好吧。我真觉得自己有点傻气。
That's cringy. So wait, we got to touch these moon rocks that were on the moon, like they're four billion year old moon rocks. I got to touch a couple moon rocks that weren't on the moon. What do you mean? Moon rocks that were on the moon. On the moon. Sorry, yeah.
太尴尬了。等等，我们得摸摸那些去过月球的月岩，就像它们是四十亿年前的月岩一样。我摸了几个没去过月球的月岩。什么意思？去过月球的月岩。月球上的。抱歉，对。
Yeah, sorry. Yeah, they were on the moon. All those scientists must have loved you. Yeah. Like, oh, guys, it's so relaxing to have an actor around. I know. One plus one can, can equal anything. I asked so many dumb, dumb questions to, I'm sure they were probably so over it, but we
对，抱歉。对，它们去过月球。所有那些科学家一定都很喜欢你。对。就像，哦，各位，身边有个演员真是太放松了。我知道。一加一可以等于任何东西。我问了好多好多蠢问题，我敢说他们肯定受够了，不过我们
got to go inside the, this vessel called the Orion. It was, it's like, what is that called, a simulator that the astronauts train in before they go to the moon. They're gonna go to the moon in this thing. This Orion thing. Did I lose you guys? Are you guys sleeping? No, it's pretty great.
得进去那个叫猎户座的飞船。那是个，那叫什么来着，宇航员去月球前训练的模拟器。他们要坐这东西去月球。这个猎户座。我把你们说懵了吗？你们睡着了吗？没有，挺棒的。
I mean, no, no, no. That's, that's interesting. I mean, I thought it was fascinating. I am one of those people. God, you get the pushback on this. I am one of those people like, we got a lot of stuff going on here. Why are we leaving the moon? I know why we're going to the moon.
我是说，不，不，不。那，那挺有意思的。我是说，我觉得这太迷人了。我就是那种人。天哪，你在这方面会遭到反对。我就是那种人，这里有那么多事要忙，我们为什么要离开月球？我知道为什么要登月。
Where are we going? We're going to the moon. God damn, we got so much shit to fix over here. But yeah, okay. But we got to get ready for Mars. We got to get ready for Mars. And I know a lot of innovation comes from that. Right.
我们要去哪？我们要去月球。妈的，我们这边有那么多烂摊子要收拾。不过好吧。但我们得为火星做准备。我们得为火星做准备。我知道很多创新都源于此。没错。
So eventually that stuff will touch us here, but isn't it mostly kind of for morale and mankind excellence and all that? What, to go to the moon? Yeah, I mean, the real practical applications to what we're, what we're doing up there. I'm saying, I don't know. I'm not doubting it. I'm just, this is from a place of total smartness. I think, yeah, there's, there's lots of things we've already discovered about the universe
所以最终那些东西会影响到我们，但难道这不主要还是为了士气、人类的卓越成就之类的事情吗？什么，去登月？对，我是说，这对我们正在做的事情有什么实际的应用价值。我说的是，我不知道。我不是在怀疑。我只是，这是从一个绝对聪明的角度出发的。我觉得，是的，我们通过登月已经发现了关于宇宙的很多事情
going to the moon. Sure. I mean, we've got a lot of innovations. As Jason said that, that he said to get, we get, touch this back here, a lot of stuff that they innovate for the program. Yeah. And I think as soon as we really nail down this whole sort of, you know, mirrors to see what yesterday actually looked like, I mean, we can really nail that down.
当然。我是说，我们有很多创新。正如杰森刚才说的，我们摸了摸后面的东西，他们为这个项目创新了很多东西。对。而且我觉得一旦我们真正搞定了这种，你知道的，用镜子来看看昨天到底长什么样，我是说，我们真的能把它搞定。
Listener, if you've got an extra hour to fall asleep, go ahead and listen to my theory. What, what, what, what was it with Sean, Sean, we can, we've had ourselves from, from our episode with Neil deGrasse Tyson, I think that that's what's happening right now. We're seeing Jason back in that time, back in two years ago. If I could find somebody intelligent enough to figure out a way to have the Hubble or the, what's the new web, the web, the web, yeah, to like fire into a mirror that then fires back into a mirror, into another, into another, into another. We won't have to, we won't see all the way back to the big bang.
听众朋友们，如果你有多余的一个小时想睡觉，那就去听听我的理论吧。什么，什么，肖恩，我们怎么了？我们和尼尔·德格拉斯·泰森那一期的节目，我觉得这就是现在正在发生的事情。我们看到了两年前的杰森。如果我能找到一个足够聪明的人，想出一种方法，让哈勃或者，那个叫什么来着，韦伯，韦伯，对，射向一面镜子，然后再反射到另一面镜子，再进另一面，另一面，另一面。我们就不用，我们就不用一直看到大爆炸了。
Like that, that seemed like that's the tough parts already done. No, we could do that. We could see Jack just into yesterday. Jay, I thought I remember you telling me that when you were on Silver Spoons in your dressing room, you used to fire into the mirror. Is that not, am I misremembering? Wait, no, Will, that's totally different, bro. That was Aaron Gray related.
就像那样，好像最难的部分已经完成了。不，我们可以做到。我们甚至能看到杰克昨天刚发生的事。杰，我记得你跟我说过，当你在拍《银匙》在化妆室里时，你也经常对着镜子开枪。是我记错了吗？等等，不，威尔，那是完全不同的，兄弟。那和亚伦·格雷有关。
It was Lee. He still, he still does that. You can find him doing that occasionally. Wait and really quick. I just want to, the last thing I want to say is Sean to you, because you brought it up. You, Sean texted me, I just want our listeners to know that you guys went on vacation. After all this, Jason, you complained about, I never get to go on vacation and blah, blah, blah.
是李。他现在，他现在还在这么干。你偶尔还能看到他这么做。等等，快说。我只想，我最后想说的是肖恩对你说的，因为你提起了这事。你，肖恩发短信告诉我，我只想让我们的听众知道，你们去度假了。在经历了这一切之后，杰森，你抱怨过，我从来都不能去度假之类的话。
You and Sean went on vacation without me. Well, you were invited. Yeah, yeah. I think you were invited. I wasn't really invited. Really? Yes, you were. Yes, you always are.
你和肖恩背着我出去度假了。好吧，你被邀请了。对，对。我觉得你是被邀请了。我其实没被邀请。真的吗？是的，你去了。是的，你总是被邀请。
You're always invited. I'm taking a big drink. No, I know. I mean, I think you guys knew that I was out here at the beach. Yeah. You're still at the beach, right? When do you come back from the nonsense? Soon, boy, I was apprehended on the street a few times from, you know, I heard that you're
你总是被邀请的。我喝了一大口。不，我知道。我是说，我想你们知道我当时在海滩这边。对。你还在海滩上，对吧？你什么时候从这些无聊的事里回来？快了，伙计，我在街上被认出来好几次，你知道的，我听说你
out here on Long Island and Bayman giving you shit for having a bunch of Range Rovers in your driveway. And then you do drive a GMC and I go, yeah, do you think we make this shit up, bro? But you do park the Range Rover next to the GMC, right? Wait. You better know it's in California. But well, I have to tell you something. I'll tell you something.
在长岛的贝曼，别人还吐槽你车道上停了一堆路虎。然后你明明开的是GMC，我说，对，你觉得这是我们瞎编的吗，兄弟？但你确实把路虎停在GMC旁边了，对吧？等等。你最好知道它在加利福尼亚。不过好吧，我得告诉你个事。我告诉你个事。
Speaking of the beach, I went, the first day I got there, me and Jason and Scotty went into the ocean. This is in the Bahamas, not in Houston. Right. We went into the ocean. We went into the ocean and I have just swim trunks on the widest person alive on the planet Earth. And this guy, Jason, has a big, thick, rimmed hat on glasses, a long-sleeved shirt, like
说到海滩，我去了，我到的第一天，我和杰森还有斯科特一起去了海里。这是在巴哈马，不是在休斯敦。对。我们去了海里。我们下了海，我只穿着沙滩裤，是地球上最白的人。而这家伙杰森，戴着一顶宽边大帽子，戴着眼镜，穿着长袖衬衫，就像
shorts down to his knees, covered, you look like you were a gardener in the middle of the ocean. No, it's the worst. I've been to the beach with him before. It's terrible. Tramp stamp. He's got a tattoo on the small of his back, but... Oh, I never saw that.
短裤垂到膝盖，遮得严严实实，你看上去就像在海中央当园丁。不，这太糟糕了。我以前跟他一起去过海滩。太可怕了。背部下方的纹身。他后腰上有个纹身，但是……哦，我从来没见过。
Well, because you were closed. It was covered. It just simply says breathe. But he's just wearing so much clothing in the ocean, right? We had this photo, Sean, when we went from Mali's 40th and we all went with all the kids down on this big vacation of four or five years ago, everybody, we're all outside. They're like 12 of us. And Jason, it looks like he's like in the Arctic.
好吧，因为你穿着衣服。被挡住了。上面简单写着“呼吸”。但他去海里时穿着实在太多衣服了，对吧？我们有一张照片，肖恩，那是四五年前我们去莫莉40岁生日，带著所有孩子去度假时拍的，所有人，我们都在外面。大概有12个人。而杰森，看起来就像在北极一样。
I know. Well, listen. I'm going to fold. Number one, I don't know if you guys have heard about sun cancer or UV rays or something. There's a couple of articles I'm going to send you. And then there's the other thing called dad bod that I don't think anybody really needs to see dad bod. No.
我知道。好吧，听着。我要认输了。第一，我不知道你们有没有听说过皮肤癌或紫外线之类的东西。我有几篇文章要发给你们。然后还有所谓的“老爸身材”，我觉得没人真想看老爸身材。不。
No one's got a worse dad bod than me. And I was out with my shirt on. Well, I'm going to send you a top. Check your mail. Will, I'm sending you a couple. You still get mail there? Guys. We were keeping our guests too long.
没人比我的老爸身材更糟糕了。我出门时都穿着衬衫。好吧，我要给你发件上衣。查收邮件。威尔，我给你发几件。你那儿还能收到信吗？伙计们。我们把嘉宾留得太久了。
All right. Listen. This is, this is incredible. Our guest today is anything but smart less. He's a spectacular, incredible talent. I could listen to him sing for 20 hours a day. He's such a smarty that he not only skipped one, but two grades growing up, starting high school at 12 years old.
好了。听着。这，这太不可思议了。我们今天的嘉宾可一点都不“聪明绝顶（SmartLess）”。他是个极其出色的天才。我能听他唱歌听上一天二十个小时。他是个超级聪明的学霸，读书时不仅跳过一级，而且是跳了两级，12岁就上高中了。
Good Lord. Just like me. Right when Jason was ending, ending my scholastic career. That's enough. His genius was not exclusive to academics. He started playing piano at four years old, which paved the way for his eventual EGOT status. Yes.
天呐。就像我一样。就在杰森结束，结束我的学术生涯的时候。够了。他的天才不仅限于学术。他4岁开始弹钢琴，这为他最终获得EGOT（艾美奖、格莱美奖、奥斯卡奖、托尼奖）地位铺平了道路。对。
He's another EGOT. So for Tracy, EGOT is Emmy, Grammy, Oscar, and Tony. He's won all of those. What? So previous jobs, which I love finding out about are like a wedding singer, a business consultant. So I'm going to ask him about that. Legend has it that it was Kanye West who helped him get signed back in the day.
他是又一个EGOT得主。所以对于特雷西来说，EGOT就是艾美奖、格莱美奖、奥斯卡奖和托尼奖。他把这些全拿下了。什么？所以他以前的工作，我最喜欢了解这些，比如婚礼歌手、商业顾问。所以我待会儿要问问他。传说当年是坎耶·韦斯特帮他签下了唱片公司。
It's Uber Towns at Mr. Smarty Pants. John Legend. Oh. Legend has it. John Legend. What the hell? He's classing up the joint. It's me.
这就是聪明人约翰·传奇（John Legend）。哦。传说中的。约翰·传奇。搞什么鬼？他给这地方增添了格调。是我。
Oh, he's got a cool shirt on too. John. Hi, everybody. Well, hello. Hi. Hi, John Legend. Look at you. What's happening?
哦，他穿的衬衫也很酷。约翰。大家好。噢，你好。嗨。嗨，约翰·传奇。瞧瞧你。怎么回事？
What is happening? Look at him. Where are you right now? I'm at my office in Los Angeles. Yeah. Look, it looks clean and simple. You don't look busy at work. This is actually Chrissy's office.
怎么回事？看看他。你现在在哪？我在洛杉矶的办公室。对。看，看起来干净又简朴。你看起来工作不忙。这其实是克莉茜的办公室。
My office is next door, which is basically a recording studio. So she has, we bought a three bedroom house basically to be our workhouse. And my recording studio is in the next room over and then this is her office. But I often do. Now, are there zoning issues with that, John? Zoning issues with having an office in a house. I've explored this before. This is a don't ask, don't tell policy, even though I just told millions of people.
我的办公室在隔壁，基本上是个录音室。所以她有，我们买了一栋三居室的房子基本上当作工作室。我的录音室在隔壁房间，然后这是她的办公室。但我经常。话说回来，约翰，这不会有什么分区规划（zoning）问题吧？在房子里设办公室的分区规划问题。我以前探讨过这个问题。这是个“不问不说”的政策，尽管我刚刚告诉了数百万人。
Yeah. Let's have the address on that real quick. Before forgiveness later, wait, before I dive too deep into this, John, I, because I'm, I don't want to get like an hour into this. How many feet back from the curb is the house? Is that where you're going to? No. Okay.
对。把那个地址报一下。先斩后奏，等等，在我深入聊这个之前，约翰，我，因为我，我不想聊个没完。这房子离马路牙子有多少英尺？你是要问这个吗？不。好吧。
So we're off of the zoning. Okay. Go ahead. No, I want it just because I'm going to forget if this goes on too long. Jesus Christ superstar. You were, that was unbelievable. That was incredible. And it was totally live.
所以我们不管分区规划了。好吧。继续。不，我问是因为如果这事说太久我会忘的。耶稣基督超级巨星。你当时，那太不可思议了。太棒了。而且完全是现场直播。
Totally live. What was that? Like two years ago, three years ago? That was 20, it was 2019, I believe. It was on NBC, I think, right? It was on NBC with Sarah Bareilles as Mary Magdalene. She was great too, man. Yeah.
完全直播。那是什么时候？大概两年前，三年前？那是20，那是2019年，我记着。好像是在NBC播出的，对吧？是在NBC播出的，萨拉·巴瑞莱斯饰演抹大拉的玛丽亚。她也很棒，伙计。对。
I mean, that show, to do that live like you did in front of all of America, that was, it was, you were incredible. It was just so great. Thank you. Didn't you win something for that? We won the Emmy for our best live special. That's so great. That was my E that made me an Egot.
我是说，那个节目，像你那样在全美观众面前进行现场直播，太厉害了，你当时太棒了。真的太棒了。谢谢。你没为那个得过什么奖吗？我们凭借最佳现场特别节目赢得了艾美奖。太棒了。那是我的E，让我成了EGOT。
That's so cool. What kind of preptice goes into something like, like how far, what is it, just months of just the rehearsal? When you're going to do it live TV, I mean, it's got to be intense. Well, you know, we're musicians, so we do live performances all the time. But doing a show like this is quite an endeavor and there's so many moving parts. There's so much crew and production and everything that needs to happen, choreography. Everything needs to go right and it was magical.
太酷了。像这样的节目需要做多少准备工作，比如要准备多久，是几个月的排练吗？当你要做电视直播时，我的意思是，一定压力很大。嗯，你知道的，我们是音乐人，所以我们经常进行现场演出。但要做这样一场演出相当不容易，有太多活动的环节了。有那么多的工作人员、制作团队和需要搞定的一切，还有编舞。一切都必须顺利进行，而那真的很神奇。
We rehearsed for a few months. It aired live on Easter Sunday and I think we started working on it in January. But then I had to go away and do a tour in Asia for a few weeks in between rehearsals. And so I come back and we rehearsed for the final week or two. But man, it was quite an endeavor, quite a great team and I love doing it. You know what, when I was a musical director at this dinner theater in the suburb of Chicago, a long story. But anyway, we did Jesus Christ Superstar and on Easter, not making this up, on Easter
我们排练了几个月。它在复活节周日现场直播，我想我们是在一月份开始筹备的。但后来中间有几周我不得不离开去亚洲巡演。所以我回来后又排练了最后的一两周。不过天哪，这真是一个巨大的工程，有一个非常棒的团队，我也很喜欢做这件事。你知道吗，当我在芝加哥郊区的一个晚餐剧场担任音乐总监时，说来话长。但不管怎样，我们排演了《耶稣基督超级巨星》，而在复活节，这不是瞎编的，在复活节
Sunday, one of the performances, the guy who played Judas, you know, where he hangs himself in the middle of the thing, in the middle of the show. Spoiler alert. Well, there's this contraption, you know, that saves him from obviously doing that. But it broke on Easter Sunday. Oh no. Wow. Well, look into that.
周日的其中一场演出中，扮演犹大的那家伙，你知道的，就是他在中间上吊自杀的那场戏，在演出中间。剧透警告。好吧，有个机关，你知道的，可以把他救下来，免得他真挂了。但那机关在复活节周日坏了。哦，不。哇。好吧，查查那个。
So he in fact was resurrected. He was resurrected. Did you play Jesus Christ or the superstar? I was in the piano. I was in the piano. I was in the piano. Oh, you came out of the piano. Well, like coming out of a cake, like coming out of the, you were in the piano.
所以他实际上死而复生了。他复活了。你是演耶稣还是超级巨星？我在钢琴里。我在钢琴里。我在钢琴里。哦，你是从钢琴里钻出来的。就像从蛋糕里钻出来一样，就像从，你在钢琴里。
Yeah, I was naked. Or did you play the piano? Another fun fact about that experience, Andrew Lloyd Webber and Tim Rice also both became EGOTS because of that same Emmy. Oh, wow. Wow. So we all, we all three got it the same day. Oh, that's pretty wild.
对，我当时一丝不挂。还是你在弹钢琴？关于那段经历的另一个有趣的事实，安德鲁·劳埃德·韦伯和蒂姆·莱斯也因为同一个艾美奖而双双成为了EGOT。哦，哇。哇。所以我们三个人在同一天拿到了。哦，这太疯狂了。
How many, how many are there of you, the EGOTS? 17. 17. Sean knows he's doing the research. Yeah, Jennifer Hudson just joined the club. She's the 17th. Yeah. Yeah.
你们这些EGOT得主一共有多少人？17个。17个。肖恩知道，他在做研究。对，詹妮弗·哈德森刚刚加入了这个俱乐部。她是第17个。对。对。
Isn't that wild? Will, where are you on the, on the list? Do you have any, you've got, you've got your Oscar and your Tony. I'm in the, I'm on the no gots. Got zero. I ain't got no gots. Got none. That's mine.
这难道不疯狂吗？威尔，你在那个名单上排第几？你有什么，你已经有了奥斯卡和托尼奖。我在“零GOTS”组。得零个。我一个都没捞着。一个没有。那是我的。
I ain't got no gots. Now, John, with all of these things that you do at such an incredibly high level and you're so in demand, how do you go about making your decisions about what to do, what to do next, how to prioritize work, got this great family too and the money. The money, of course. Yeah. It's all about the money. Yeah, of course.
我一个都没捞着。话说回来，约翰，你以如此高的水准做所有这些事情，而且如此抢手，你是如何决定接下来要做什么、如何安排工作优先级的？还有这个美满的家庭，以及金钱。钱，当然。对。全是为了钱。对，当然。
I got it. No. Honestly, I, I'm very fortunate. I get to make choices. And so I do stuff that I'm excited about, do stuff I'm passionate about, do stuff I think I'll be really good at doing and they do have to pay me well. So all of that comes into the decision. But I would imagine that your interests change pretty quickly.
我懂。不。说实话，我很幸运。我能够有所选择。所以我做那些让我兴奋的事，做我充满热情的事，做我觉得自己能做得很棒的事，当然它们也得付给我丰厚的报酬。所以所有这些因素都会纳入决策中。不过我想你的兴趣变化得挺快的吧？
Like, how do you, how are you certainly with, with theater, you have to commit so far out in advance, how do you ever get nervous that you're going to commit to start rehearsals on a play in six months? That's going to run 12 months and, but then all of a sudden something comes along in the television world that works quicker, that might be at odds with that scheduling wise. Like, does that ever give you, uh, audited about making choices? Well, I haven't actually done Broadway. I only did that live performance.
比如，你怎么，特别是对于戏剧，你必须提前很久做出承诺，你难道从来不会担心自己会答应在六个月后开始排练一部话剧吗？这部话剧要演12个月，但突然之间电视界出现了一些节奏更快、可能在时间安排上与之冲突的机会？这会不会让你，呃，对做决定感到焦虑？好吧，我其实还没演过百老汇。我只做过那次现场演出。
We did it, uh, Saturday and Sunday of Easter weekend and that was it. So we just rehearsed and did the show, uh, that weekend and, uh, I didn't do like a long run on Broadway, like a lot of artists and actors will do. So I haven't had to make that decision yet. Do you want to? It would be a tough one, honestly, because it takes a lot of time, a lot of energy. Yeah. Um, and you can uncheck that money box.
我们在复活节周末的周六和周日演了那场，就那样。所以我们就在那个周末排练并完成了演出，呃，我并没有像很多艺术家和演员那样在百老汇进行长期驻演。所以我还没做过那样的决定。你想去吗？老实说，这会是个艰难的决定，因为它需要大量的时间和精力。对。呃，而且你可以把金钱那一栏划掉。
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, but, but also, you know, my, my kids go to school in Los Angeles and I would want to be with them and it would be hard to make that decision. Honestly. Yeah. How old are the kids? My daughter's six and my son is four.
对。对。哦，但是，呃，你知道的，我的，我的孩子在洛杉矶上学，我希望能和他们在一起，要做出那个决定会很难。老实说。对。孩子们多大了？我女儿六岁，儿子四岁。
Oh my gosh. Wow. Oh yeah. You're right in it, man. Going back to at the beginning in the intro, when I said you skipped grades and you entered high school at 12 years old, that's just crazy pants. What did you, how did, did you feel like you missed out by skipping or did you want to skip or were you pressured by your parents or teachers or?
哦，天哪。哇。哦，对。你正处于焦头烂额的时候，伙计。回到节目开头的时候，我在介绍里说你跳级了，12岁就上了高中，这简直太疯狂了。你觉得跳级让你失去了什么吗？还是你自己想跳级的？或者是受到了父母或老师的施压？
Well, it was my mother that was definitely pushing it. And I honestly wouldn't advise it for most kids and I think you do lose out socially when you try to put a kid that's 12 and a group of 14 year olds. I think it's, it's hard, you know? Yeah. And I was super shy. But you know, music was my way of connecting with people and I think music kind of saved me from being just completely antisocial and complete geek.
嗯，肯定是我的母亲在极力推动这事。老实说，我不建议大多数孩子这么做，我觉得当你把一个12岁的孩子塞进14岁的群体里时，你在社交上的确会有所损失。我觉得这挺难的，你知道吗？对。而且我超级害羞。不过你知道，音乐是我与人连接的方式，我觉得音乐某种程度上拯救了我，让我没有完全变成一个反社会的人和死宅。
But honestly, it's tough and I don't think I would advise anyone to do it with their kids. I wouldn't do it with my kids either. Right. Was there a reason for that? Like was there, was it going to help you sort of with your music? Was it going to give you more opportunities earlier? Was that part of it?
但说实话，这很艰难，我想我不会建议任何人让自己的孩子这么做。我以后也不会让我的孩子这么做。对。这有什么原因吗？比如是为了对你的音乐有帮助？能让你更早获得更多机会？这也是其中的一部分吗？
No. My mom, I think it was almost like a badge of honor for her because she homeschooled us for a while and she liked the idea that her son was so well prepared that he could test out of, you know, two levels above where he was supposed to be. Right. And so I think it was almost like her proving the worth of her home teaching, uh, saying when I came back to public school, I was two years ahead of my peers and I could be skipped to eighth grade when I was supposed to be in sixth.
没有。我妈妈，我觉得这几乎成了她的一种荣誉勋章，因为她在家教我们一段时间，她很喜欢这种想法，她的儿子准备得如此充分，以至于可以通过考试跳过比他原本年级高两级的课程。对。所以我觉得这几乎就像她在证明自己家庭教育的价值，说当我回到公立学校时，我比同龄人超前了两年，本来该上六年级的时候可以直接跳到八年级。
So I think honestly, that's what motivated it more than anything. Where was that? What part of the country was that? I grew up in Springfield, Ohio, which is about 50 minutes west of Columbus. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So that was a real early declaration that you were making that it's going to be music I'm all in and, uh, was there, did you feel any pressure like, well, God, I better keep
所以老实说，我觉得比起其他任何事，这才是推动她的动力。那是哪里？那是哪个地方？我在俄亥俄州的斯普林菲尔德长大，距离哥伦布以西大约50分钟车程。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。所以你很早就公开表态了，你认定这就是音乐，你全身心投入，呃，当时有没有感到什么压力，比如，天哪，我最好不断变得更好、更好、更好，因为我全身心投入了这个职业，而我不是，你知道的，在尝试，对。
getting better and better and better and better because I'm like all in on this career and I'm not, you know, trying to, yeah. I was straddling, uh, for a long time because, you know, I was a really good student and I, uh, went to Ivy League school after high school and I studied English as a major and then went on to be a management consultant as Sean mentioned in my intro. Yeah. I want to know that. And so I, I was doing other things that could be like backup plans, even though I thought
我有一段时间两边兼顾，因为，你知道的，我曾经是个好学生，高中毕业后我去了常春藤盟校，主修英语，然后就像肖恩在介绍里提到的那样，去当了一名管理咨询师。对。我想知道这个。所以我当时，我还在做其他可以作为备选计划的事情，尽管我认为音乐确实是我真正想做并想全身心投入的事业。而且我从小就热爱音乐、创作音乐。但我的学业和毕业后的其他工作，始终为我提供了一点安全感，但我真心一直想做我现在正在做的事情。肖恩在我15岁的时候写过一篇文章，那是为了黑人历史月写的，麦当劳是那篇文章的赞助商，呃，那场比赛的主题是“明天的未来黑人历史创造者”，那是一个征文比赛，他们问你打算如何创造黑人
music really was the thing I wanted to do and wanted to commit to. And I had been loving music and been making music since I was a kid. But I always had, you know, a little bit of insurance, you know, with my academics and with, you know, other jobs coming out of school, but I truly always wanted to do what I'm doing right now. Sean wrote an essay when I was 15, it was for a black history month and, uh, McDonald's was the sponsor for the essay and, uh, the, the competition was the future black history makers of tomorrow and it was an essay competition and they said, how you plan to make black
历史。我在15岁时写道，呃，我将要，呃，成为一名著名的音乐家，并且我要利用我作为音乐家的地位来帮助我的社区。这太棒了。我知道我想做这件事，呃，但中间有很多弯路和备选计划，我一路上都在坚持，直到它最终融合在一起，而这一切开始融合是在我开始和坎耶合作的时候，当我开始与他以及他制作的艺术家们进行大量合作的时候。
history. And I said at age 15 that, uh, I was going to, uh, become a famous musician and I was going to use my position as a musician to help my community. That's amazing. I knew that I wanted to do this, uh, but there were a lot of detours and backup plans that I kept going along the way until it finally kind of all came together and it started to come together when I started working with Kanye, when I started to get, uh, a lot of collaborations with him and with the artists he was producing.
而且，呃，在经历了大约六年的尝试、从宾大毕业五年后的2004年，我终于得到了一份唱片合约。太棒了。然后坎耶，你们第一次见面，那，那是怎样的过程？他是在芝加哥长大的。我在俄亥俄州长大，呃，我在大学里的室友，呃，在密苏里州堪萨斯城长大，但他刚好是坎耶的表弟，呃，所以我的室友德冯（Devon），我和他至今仍是很好的朋友，他也是个音乐人、非常有创意的人和企业家。
And, um, I finally got a record deal in 2004 after about six years of trying five years after I graduated from, uh, Penn. That's amazing. And then Kanye, uh, first meet, what was, what was that process? So he grew up in Chicago. I grew up in Ohio and, um, my roommate in college, uh, grew up in Kansas city, Missouri, but he was Kanye's cousin and, uh, so my roommate, DeVon, um, who I'm still very good friends with and he's also a musician and really creative person and entrepreneur.
总之，当时我在纽约四处演出，白天做着管理咨询的工作。然后，呃，我会邀请朋友们来看我的演出，接着德冯开始和我的乐队一起当DJ。然后，呃，有一次他邀请他的表弟来看演出，他的表弟坎耶刚刚从芝加哥搬来，住在纽约市外，呃，跨过哈德逊河的泽西。而且，呃，他说：“我要邀请我表弟来看演出。你们应该见见，呃，你们以后应该合作一下。”
Anyway, I was playing gigs around New York, uh, and working as a management consultant during the day. And, uh, I would invite my friends out to my gigs and then DeVon started DJing with my band. And, uh, one time he invited his cousin to the show, his cousin Kanye had just moved from Chicago, was living outside of New York, uh, across the, uh, the Hudson in Jersey. And, um, he was like, I'm going to invite my cousin to the show. You guys should meet and, uh, you guys should collaborate at some point.
那时候坎耶还不是什么大制作人，在我看来他只是德冯的表弟，但他，呃，刚开始和Jay-Z合作，刚开始和Roc-A-Fella唱片公司的人合作，呃，比如孟菲斯·布里克（Memphis Bleek）和比尼·西格尔（Beanie Sigel），所有Jay在Roc-A-Fella唱片公司早期签下的艺术家，呃，你知道的。而且，呃，他开始作为一名抢手的嘻哈制作人崭露头角，我们开始合作，他，呃，为我的一些小样歌曲制作伴奏，而我也会和他一起写他的小样，然后，你知道的，我的小样最终变成了我的首张专辑《Get Lifted》。而他的小样最终成了他的首张专辑《The College Dropout》。
And Kanye wasn't a big producer at this time. He was just, uh, DeVon's cousin as far as I was concerned, but he, um, had just started working with Jay-Z. He just started working with folks in, uh, Rockefeller records, uh, like Memphis Bleak and Beanie Siegel, all the artists that Jay had signed, um, you know, in that early time of, uh, Rockefeller records. And, um, he was starting to become known as an in-demand hip-hop producer and we started working together and he was, uh, producing some of my demo songs and I would write with
而且，呃，我的成功很大程度上要归功于他。哇。当你找到你这一生想做的事，然后和志同道合的人混在一起时，事情就会发生，一切就会水到渠成，这真是太棒了。我总是说，运气就是机会遇到准备，但你知道的，你必须让自己处于能够利用这种机会的位置上，呃，而让自己处于这种位置的一部分，就是所有的排练、所有的准备、所有那些现场演出——当时可能只有，你知道的，50个人在场，100个人在场——然后其中的另一部分就是，你知道的，敞开心扉去结识不同的人，并且，呃，与不同的人建立联系。我开始这么做了，特别是在我住在纽约的时候，我遇到了很多帮助我职业生涯发展的人，最后这一切终于融合在了一起。哇。你，你更喜欢歌词创作，还是音乐创作，或者是表演？
him on his demo and, you know, my demo eventually became my debut album, Get Lifted. And his eventually became his debut album, College Dropout. And, uh, he has a lot to do with my success. Wow. It's amazing when you, when you find the thing that you want to do with your life and then you just hang out with like-minded people, shit happens and stuff comes together. I always say luck is when opportunity meets preparation, but you know, you got to put yourself in positions to take advantage of it and, uh, part of putting yourself in that
你会，你会如何，你会如何给这些事情排序？我喜欢写作。写作很有趣。我其实不会把音乐和歌词分开，因为我在写作时它们是如此紧密地交织在一起。我们，呃，通常是两三个人坐在一个房间里寻找灵感，呃，我通常在想出歌词之前先想出旋律。所以当我写一首，一首，一首旋律时，其实只是我在哼唱一些毫无意义的词。
position is all the rehearsal, all the prep, all the performances you did when only, you know, 50 people were there, 100 people were there and then part of it is just, you know, opening yourself up to meeting different people and, and, uh, connecting with different people. And I started to do that, especially when I was living in New York and I was meeting lots of folks who helped my career along and it finally came together. Wow. Do you, do you enjoy the, the lyric writing more than the music writing more than the performing?
我管它叫我的，呃，哼唱轨。所以我的手机里有一堆录音，都是我在哼唱一些没意义的东西。对，对。所以不是吉他，不是钢琴，只是你在哼唱？嗯，它可能是在钢琴伴奏上，或者吉他伴奏上，或者制作人正在寻找歌词的伴奏上。对。只是为了寻找节奏感。
How would, how would you, how would you stack those things in- I love writing. Writing is fun. I don't really separate the music and the lyric because it's so intertwined when I'm writing. We, uh, usually it's usually two or three of us sitting in a room just vibing and, uh, I usually come up with a melody before I come up with a lyric. And so when I write a, a, a melody, it's just me humming nonsense.
所以当我写《Ordinary People》时，我说的是，而且它现在还没什么意义，但我弄明白了它听起来是什么样的，以及它可能听起来是什么样的。对。我喜欢这个。完全正确。肖恩。完全正确。而且，呃，所以我录下了这个哼唱轨，然后这些哼唱会启发不同的
I call it my, uh, mumble track. So I have a bunch of recordings on my phone and me mumbling nonsense. Yeah, yeah. So it's not like a guitar, not a piano, it's just you mumbling. Well, it may be over a piano or over a guitar or over a track that a producer is trying to find the words. Yeah. Just trying to find the flow.
音调、想法和节奏，接着歌词自然而然地就从这里诞生了。整个过程通常需要我大约三到四个小时，呃，通常是我和另一个人。有时我自己一个人做。然后我会在那次会议结束时录制一个小样。这就是我的工作日。你知道的，所以你有，我刚才差点直接跳到这次采访的尾声，但你有一张即将发行的新专辑叫《Legend》，当然了，名字就叫这个，为什么我们没做过一张叫这名字的专辑？对。
So when I write ordinary people, I'm saying, and it doesn't make any sense yet, but I figure out what it sounds like and what it might sound like. Yeah. I love that. Exactly. Sean. Exactly. And, uh, so I record this mumble track and then the mumbles kind of suggests different
你的名字里就带着呢。而且，它，它，它是一张双专辑，我听了每一首歌。太棒了。首先，谢谢。对。
tones and ideas and rhythms, and then eventually the lyric comes from that. And that whole process usually takes me about three, four hours, uh, usually me and another person. Sometimes I do it by myself. And then I'll record a demo in that, the end of that session. And that's my work day. You know, so you have the, I was, I'm cutting way to the end of this interview, but you have this new album coming out called legend, which of course is like, of course it's called
对。我不知道他们已经把专辑给你了。所以，对。这是绝密，绝密。我总是很高兴听到有人听过它，因为，呃，我觉得它作为我的小秘密已经藏了好久了。对。
like, why didn't we do an album called that? Yeah. It's right there in your name. And it's, it's a, it's a, it's a double album and it's, I listen to every single track. It's so great. First of all, Thank you. Yeah.
我，我，我会发推特。我会发推特的。好吧，不，对。肖恩，你已经这么干了。它已经上传了。我今天早上才听的。对。直接盗版。
Yeah. I didn't know they'd given to you yet. So I'm, Yeah. It's secret secret. I'm always excited that somebody's heard it because, uh, it's, I feel like it's been my little secret for so long. Yeah.
就像火一样。哦，对。对。我刚刚一直在卖。我刚刚在运河街下百老汇把它卖了半小时。卖得挺好。现在没人买那些东西了。卖得相当好，伙计。
I, I, I'll tweet it. I'll tweet it. Well, no, yeah. Sean, you already did that. It's upload. I listened to it just this morning. Yeah. Just rip.
好吧，谢谢。对。不，但我只想聊其中几首歌，因为它们，它们太棒了。你知道，呃，“All She Wants to Do Is Dance”听起来会是一首超级、超级、超级、超级热门的歌。就像，我希望如此。我在听的时候跟着哼唱，然后心想：哦，转调要来了。
It's like fire and nasty. Oh yeah. Yeah. And I just been selling it. I just been selling them on lower Broadway at canal for the last half hour. It's done well. No one buys those anymore. It's done really well, dude.
转调来了。音调升高了。你知道的，就像，我听它是因为他在那儿唱，啦啦啦啦啦啦啦，他在做哼唱测试。对。太棒了。
Well, thank you. Yeah. No, but I want to just talk about a couple of the songs because they're, they're so great. You know, the, um, all she want to do is dance is going to be like a mega, mega, mega, mega hit song. Like, I hope so. I hummed it back as I was listening to it and I was like, oh, the key change is coming.
每场婚礼都会播放这首歌。但接着我听了其他一些歌，其中有些听起来真的很性感、很酷，像，你知道的，呃，一，有些歌是关于性爱的。肯定的。对。很多关于，比如“Splash Splash”的歌。你的一些歌词，呃，而且我是个同性恋。
There's the key change. It goes up. You know, it's like, I was listening to it because he was going, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. He was doing a mumbo check. Yeah. It's so good.
所以我不太懂这个。你说“我要让你湿透床单”。我们刚刚爆出了一个大新闻。好吧，你好，肖恩。等一下。作为一个同性恋，作为Gay，我可不想长大了还尿床。所以，但你说的是，我要，我要让她湿透床单。
Every wedding will play that song with it. But then I was listening to like a bunch of other, the other stuff and it's, some of it's really kind of like sexy, cool, like, you know, uh, one, one of some songs about sex. Definitely. Yeah. A lot of songs about, like Splish Splash. Some of your lyrics are, um, and I'm, I'm gay.
好吧。所以，好吧。总之。她会把我弄到另一张床上吗？等一下，这样。你有什么关于床单上的洞的歌词吗？抱歉。是个关于性爱的。抱歉。我不知道。怎么回事？所以，这些歌其实都很棒。约翰，当你，当你没在做所有这些你很擅长的不可思议的事情时，你有什么虽然不太擅长但真的很喜欢用来打发闲暇时光的爱好吗？比如你对网球上瘾吗？
So I don't get this. I'm going to make you wet the bed. You said. We just made some news right there. Well, hello Sean. Wait a minute. As a gay, as a gay guy, I don't want to grow up wetting the bed. So, but you say I'm going to, I'm going to make her wet the bed.
比如你喜欢看老套的电视节目吗？我有一个，我喜欢玩填字游戏。哦，对。我也是。我喜欢玩填字游戏。我一直在玩《纽约时报》的填字游戏App，而且我玩得相当不错。所以我不知道自己该不该说我不太擅长，因为我玩得挺好。威尔在Wordle和其他那些游戏上可以说是，呃，非常专业。
Well. So, okay. Yeah. Anyway. Will she get me in the other bed? Wait, this way. Do you have anything about the hole in the sheet? I'm sorry.
你玩过那个了吗？我还没玩过Wordle。我所有朋友都在玩，但我还是坚持玩填字游戏。我知道《纽约时报》也把Wordle买下来了，但我还是坚持玩填字游戏。填字游戏挺好的。填字游戏太棒了。《纽约时报》。Wordle也还行。
It's a sex. Sorry. I don't know. What's going on? So the, the, the songs are great though. John, when you, when you're not doing all these incredible things you do well, what do you do not as well, but really enjoy filling your free time with? You got like a tennis addiction.
挺不错的。Wordle嘛，就是那种，我玩octordle，也就是同时玩八个Wordle。cordle怎么说？对。还有cordle。我也玩cordle，但octordle才是真正的。那个叫什么，呃，有点像“说出那首歌名”的游戏？哦，对。
You got like a cheesy TV show watching. I have a, I love to do crosswords. Oh yeah. Me too. I love to do crosswords. I'm all over the New York Times crossword app, but I'm pretty good at it. So I don't know if I'll say I don't do it as well because I do it pretty well. Will's pretty, uh, pretty professional at Wordle and all that stuff.
我听说过那个。对。我想玩那个。我那个不行。我只能做周一的填字游戏，呃，因为我，我没那么聪明。你呢？你能做完哪天的？我整周的都做。
You gotten into that yet? I haven't gotten into Wordle. All my friends are doing it, but I'm sticking with the crossword. I know New York times bought Wordle too, but I'm sticking with the crossword. Crossword is good. The crossword is great. New York time. Wordle's okay.
每天都做。他当然每天都做。你都做完了吗？我都做完了。是的。顺利完成。我是在片场长大的。我，呃，我可不是。
It's pretty. Wordle's just kind of, I do octordle, which is eight wordles at simultaneous. What happened to the cordle? Yeah. And cordle. I do cordle as well, but octordle is the real. What's the one, uh, there's one with the name that tune kind of. Oh yeah.
我知道。我是说，听着，如果有些答案是关于灯光器材部门的，或者是，哦，对。我有一套C形灯架。我需要一个四英尺的柔光板过来。对。怎么催促你的出工时间。不过这需要耐心。
I heard about that. Yeah. I want to play that. I'm bad at that. I can't, I can only do Monday's crossword, uh, cause I'm, I'm less than bright. What about you? How far do you get? I do it all week.
这需要耐心。你只要坚持下去就行了。约翰，我，我，我得说，顺着杰森刚才的话。我是说，你当时，从某种角度来看，你有那么多可以做的事情。比如你受过高等教育。你当时，跟我说说咨询工作的事吧？你刚才一笔带过了。就像，等等，什么？
Every, every day. Of course he does it every day. Are you finishing them? I'm finishing them. Yes. To completion. I grew up on a, on a soundstage. I'm, uh, I'm not.
你还有过另一段完全不同的职业生涯。那是什么？嗯，所以我是在99年从宾大毕业的，宾大是一个非常商业化的地方。我们在那里有沃顿商学院，呃，你知道的，我们上一任总统就是在那儿上学的，呃，很多，呃，未来的CEO都在那儿上学。所以宾大有一种浓厚的准商业氛围，即使你不上商学院也能感受到。所以我上了文理学院，主修英语，但我的很多朋友
I know. I mean, look, if some of the answers were about the grip department or like, you know, Oh yeah. I had a set of C stand. I need a four by floppy over here. Yeah. How to push your call time. It's about patience though.
都在申请所有这些，呃，咨询公司和，和金融工作。然后你会觉得，好吧，既然学校里的其他人都在做这个，也许我应该，呃，至少去了解一下。所以，呃，我开始去参加，呃，这些宣讲会，如果你对这些工作感兴趣的话，一些校友会来学校跟你谈谈。其中一场，呃，是为可能对咨询感兴趣的有色人种学生举办的活动。
It's about patience. You just got to keep at it. John, I, I, I will say like the kind of to what Jason was saying. I mean, you had, uh, in a way you had so many things that you could have done. Like you're really educated. You were like, talk to me about the consultancy. Like you just kind of glossed over that. Like, wait, what?
我坐在了，呃，一位我挺熟悉的校友旁边，她非常聪明、很有吸引力，跟我讲了她做的工作。呃，所以我申请了波士顿咨询集团（Boston Consulting Group），也就是她工作的地方。我得到了这份工作，他们给我的年薪是5万美元，这对我当时来说是一大笔钱。我父亲是，呃，一个流水线工人。我母亲是个全职家庭主妇。所以我得到的大学毕业第一年薪水，实际上比我父亲作为流水线工人一年挣的钱还要多。
You had a whole other career. What is that? Well, so I graduated from Penn and 99 and Penn is a very business oriented kind of place. We have the Wharton school there, which, uh, you know, is where our last president went to school and, uh, lots of, uh, you know, future CEOs go to school there. So it's got kind of like a pre-business kind of vibe at Penn, even if you don't go to the business school. So I went to the college of arts and sciences, majored in English, but a lot of my friends
所以我当时想，天哪，我大概应该接受这份工作。虽然我知道自己想做音乐，但是，你知道的，反正我也得工作。我还有贷款要还。我要付房租。而且，呃，我想我不如找一份薪水还不错的工作。我也学到了一些东西，你知道的，我遇到了很多有趣的人，呃，
were applying to all these, uh, uh, consultancies and, and, uh, finance jobs. And you know, you feel like, well, if everyone else at school is doing this, maybe I should, you know, at least check it out. And so, uh, I started going to, you know, these like orientation meetings that, you know, if you're interested in these jobs, some of the alums would come to the school and talk to you about them. And one of them, uh, was an event for, uh, black and brown students who might be interested in consulting.
我以为我只会在那里干一年左右，然后我就会得到一份唱片合约，那就这样了。我在99年开始在那里工作，待了三年，然后又为我们的一个公益客户工作了一年左右。接着我终于离得到唱片合约超级近了，我开始和坎耶一起巡演。也就是在那时，我终于觉得我不需要再做日间工作了，呃，而且从你的公益项目中拿到了足够的钱，对吧？
I sat down next to, uh, an alum who I knew pretty well and she was really smart and engaging and told me about what she did. And, uh, so I applied to, uh, Boston Consulting Group, which is where she worked. And I got the job and they offered me 50 grand a year, which for me at that time was a lot of money. My dad was a, uh, uh, an assembly line worker. My mom stayed at home. So I literally was offered more in my first year coming out of school than my dad had
公益项目是怎么回事？对。我听不清任何人说话。我的听力太糟糕了。你有多大程度想去，呃，原谅我的无知。如果你已经把这个搞得风生水起的话。很久以前就很难做了。呃，去创造一个，比如说你在你的王国里的管理咨询公司？
ever made in a year, uh, as an assembly line worker. And so I'm like, man, I should probably take this job. And I knew I wanted to do music, but, you know, it's like, I'm going to have to work anyway. I got loans to pay back. I got rent to pay. And, uh, I figured I might as well work in a job that pays me pretty well. And, uh, I learned some things, you know, I met a lot of interesting people and, uh,
你知道的，我确信你现在也把它搞得风生水起，还有坎耶的东西以及你其他朋友的事情，比如说，你会给这些人打电话说：“嘿，我确信你有一个很棒的商业经纪人和一个很棒的唱片公司以及所有其他东西，但你知道的，我们可以在这里融合一下，一加一可以等于三。”你的大脑还会往那个方向思考吗？我觉得它仍然会这么想，但我真心更喜欢呆在创意方面。所以我身边有非常优秀的人在和我合作。我觉得，呃，管理咨询为我做的事，是让我做好了准备，呃，让我变得擅长
I thought I would only work there for like a year and I would get a record deal and that would be that. And I started there in 99 and I stayed there for three years and then I worked for our, one of our pro bono clients for another year or so. And then I finally was getting super close to getting a record deal and I started touring with Kanye. And that's when I finally felt like I didn't have to have a day job and, uh, was getting enough money from your pro bono, right?
我原以为我在那儿最多干一年就能拿到唱片合约，然后就行了。我在99年开始在那儿干，待了三年，后来又为一个、我们的一个公益客户干了一年左右。接着我终于离拿到唱片合约超级近了，我开始和坎耶一起巡演。也就是在那时，我终于觉得自己不需要有一份全职工作了，而且，呃，从你们的公益项目拿到了足够的钱，对吧？
What is the deal with pro bono? Yeah. I don't know what anybody's saying. My hearing is so terrible. How tempting is it for you to, uh, to, and pardon my ignorance. If you've already got this up and running. Hard to do a long time ago. Um, to create like, I mean, what about management consultant in your kingdom?
公益项目是怎么回事？是的。我不知道大家在说啥。我的听力太糟糕了。你有多大程度想去，呃，请原谅我的无知，如果你已经把这个搞定并运作起来了，很久以前很难办的事，嗯，去创建一个，我是说，管理咨询在你的王国里怎么样？
You know, which I'm sure you've got up and running now as well as perhaps, you know, Kanye stuff and any of your other friends, like, are you calling these folks and saying, Hey, I'm sure you've got a great business manager and a great label and all that other stuff, but you know, we could kind of commingle here and one plus one could make three. Like, does your brain still work in that lane? I think it still does, but I truly enjoy being on the creative side more. And so I have really good people that work with me. I think what the, uh, management consulting did for me was prepare me, uh, to be good
你知道的，我确信你现在也把它搞定并运行起来了，还有坎耶的东西以及你的其他朋友们的事务，比如，你会打电话给这些人说，嘿，我确信你有一个很棒的商业经理和一个很棒的唱片公司以及所有那些其他东西，但你知道的，我们可以在这里某种程度上融合一下，一加一可以等于三。比如，你的大脑还在那个赛道上运作吗？我想它还在，但我真的更喜欢在创意这一边。所以我身边有非常优秀的人在帮我。我认为管理咨询为我做的是让我做好准备，去成为一个
at hiring people and, and bringing people into my world that I could trust. I hold a pretty high standard for everybody that works with me and I think they're really good at what they do. But I think my standard was set higher by being in that setting with all these other smart people and it helps me be a good client. Honestly, a tough client, but it helps me, uh, it makes me a better client for all the people that work for me because I asked the right questions and expect a lot from them. And I really do focus on the creative.
善于雇人，把我信任的人带进我的世界。我对所有和我共事的人要求都很高，而且我认为他们都很擅长他们做的事。但我觉得，正是因为和所有这些聪明人呆在那种环境中，才把我的标准拔高了，这也让我成为了一个好客户。说实话，是个要求严格的客户，但它帮了我，呃，它让我成为所有为我工作的人心目中更好的客户，因为我会问正确的问题，对他们抱有很高的期望。我真的很专注于创意。
I spend almost all my energy focused on writing songs, uh, creating art focused on my show. And, um, and then I allow all the smart people around me to help me handle the business. I'm still looking for them. And now a word from our sponsor. And now back to the show. Going back to like singing live, like superstar touring. I'm always fascinated by people like you who have this muscle, this, this voice of yours that is so trained that you can sing night after night after night after night after
我几乎把所有的精力都花在了写歌上，呃，创作专注于我的节目的艺术。然后，呃，我让身边所有聪明的人帮我处理业务。我还在找他们。现在播一条赞助商广告。我们现在回到节目中。回到现场演唱的话题，比如超级巨星巡演。我总是对你们这样的人着迷，你们拥有这种肌肉，这种嗓音，经过如此高强度的训练，你可以日复一日、夜复一日、夜复一日地演唱
night and not damage it. Like how do you have any kind of nightmare touring stories where something went wrong or. Yeah. I mean, you're saying that I'm like, wow, well, I wish it was that, uh, easy to maintain these things. But my voice, it definitely fails me sometimes and, uh, I'm able to usually get through it. Um, but there are definitely times when it's not as strong as I would like it to be.
而不伤害它。比如，你有没有过那种出了问题的可怕巡演经历？有。我是说，你这么一说，我就想，哇，我希望维持这些东西能有那么简单。但我的嗓子有时确实会罢工，呃，我通常能够挺过去。呃，但确实有些时候，它没有我想象的那么强。
It's part of your body. So it's not, uh, you know, it's subject to all the frailties that human beings have. Yeah. Um, just like athletes have rough nights, just like they get sore, just like all of those things. Where, where you take the microphone and you just hand it out to the audience and they finish you with lyrics for you. Sometimes you're like, uh, I was doing that in Europe just now because I got a little
它是你身体的一部分。所以它不是，呃，你知道的，它受制于人类所有的脆弱。是的。呃，就像运动员会有状态不好的时候，就像他们会酸痛，就像所有这些情况一样。你拿着麦克风，直接把它递给观众，让他们替你唱完歌词。有时你会想，呃，我刚才在欧洲时就在那样做，因为我有点
bit under the weather and you know, your body tells on you and your voice tells on you when you're under the weather, when you're tired, when you're dehydrated, any of those things. So it's a struggle every time. Um, that means you have to take care of yourself. Uh, I don't drink when I'm on tour. I drink a lot of water, drink a lot of tea. Um, and, uh, I have to watch my acid intake because acid reflux affects our voices. Um, all of these things.
身体不适。你知道的，当你身体不适、疲惫、脱水或有任何这些情况时，你的身体会出卖你，你的嗓音也会出卖你。所以每一次都是一场斗争。呃，这意味着你必须照顾好自己。呃，我巡演时不喝酒。我喝很多水，喝很多茶。呃，呃，我还得注意酸性食物的摄入，因为胃酸反流会影响我们的嗓音。所有这些。
And then I have to get enough rest. And if I don't get enough rest, my body tells on me, my voice tells on me too. So all of these things, uh, require maintenance and, uh, and then a lot of good warming up and cooling down before and after every show. How much sleep are you getting a night, John? What's your, what's your afternoon? On tour, I usually sleep about six or seven at night and then I'll take a nap, uh, like in the middle of the day, a siesta, uh, around, you know, two or three for a couple hours.
然后我还必须获得充足的休息。如果我没有得到充足的休息，我的身体就会出卖我，我的嗓音也会出卖我。所以所有这些，呃，都需要保养，呃，还有在每场演出前后都要做大量的充分的热身和放松。约翰，你一晚上睡几个小时？你的午休是怎样的？在巡演时，我通常晚上睡大约六、七个小时，然后我会在白天，呃，比如正午小憩一会儿，大约在两、三点左右睡上几个小时。
And then so total, I'll end up with like eight or nine hours of sleep a day. Are you touring with the six and the four year old? Uh, they were with me in Europe and in Egypt just now. Um, and then they'll come out to my Vegas residency sometimes as well. And they love it. They love coming to my shows, uh, when we let them stay up late. Well, how does your sleep love that? You know, are they, they're, they work real cooperative with daddy getting seven or eight.
所以总的来说，我一天最终能睡到八、九个小时。你巡演带着那个六岁和四岁的孩子吗？呃，他们刚才在欧洲和埃及一直陪着我。呃，有时他们也会去我在拉斯维加斯的驻唱现场。他们很喜欢。每当我们让他们熬夜时，他们都喜欢来看我的演出。好吧，那你的睡眠喜欢这样吗？你知道的，他们，他们跟爸爸配合得很好，能让你睡七八个小时？
They don't care. They jump right in. They let me take a nap. They do, uh, my wife and my, uh, and our nanny, uh, they, they keep them out of my room when I'm taking a nap. But, uh, you know, they really love music. They love coming to my shows and they really respect what I do and try to honor that, uh, so far. Yeah.
他们才不在乎呢。他们直接就扑上来了。他们让我午睡。他们会的，我妻子和我的，呃，还有我们的保姆，呃，在我午睡时，他们把孩子们挡在我的房间外面。但，呃，你知道的，他们真的很喜欢音乐。他们喜欢来看我的演出，而且他们真的很尊重我的工作，并努力尊重这一点，呃，目前为止是这样的。是的。
You got to get a lot of sleep if you're going to be people magazine sexiest man alive. Snap. Yeah. You know, I've been trying to sleep my way into it. You know what I mean? Yeah. For a while. You have to sleep with a lot of people.
如果你想成为《人物》杂志评选的在世最性感男士，你得睡很多觉。啪。是的。你知道的，我一直试图通过睡觉来赢得这个称号。你知道我的意思吗？是的。有一段时间。你必须和很多人睡觉。
You have to sleep with. I don't know what you have to do, but I'm not, whatever it is, I'm not doing. John, can you give him some phone numbers? Yeah. But I mean, that's, that's pretty, uh, when that happened, where you like, I mean, God, you must have got, it's great, but you also must get ribbed by your friends and people, you know, It is, it is the ultimate double-edged sword because, uh, they're saying something very
你必须和。我不知道你必须做什么，但不管是什么，我都没做。约翰，你能给他们一些电话号码吗？好吧。但我是说，那挺，呃，当那件事发生时，你是不是，我是说，天哪，你一定，这很棒，但你肯定也会被你的朋友和认识的人取笑吧？是的，这绝对是一把双刃剑，因为，呃，他们在说关于你的好话，
nice about you and they're making this beautiful spread about you, but it just invites everyone on the internet to say why you didn't deserve it. Right. Now I apologize. I didn't see your spread for that, but do you have to do a bunch of real quote unquote sexy shots for, for the sexiest man issue? Yeah, like, you know, wet, wet shirts. Oh no, like a lot of smoke in the eyes looks real hard looks and stuff.
他们为你做了精美的专题报道，但这只会招来互联网上的所有人来评头论足，说你为什么不配得到这个称号。对。现在，我得道个歉，我没看你那个专题报道，但为了“最性感男士”那一期，你是不是得拍一堆所谓的“性感”照片？对，比如，呃，湿衬衫。哦不，比如眼里有很多烟雾效果，看起来眼神很犀利的那种。
Again, this is perfect for me. It's hilarious. You always look like there's a fire in the room, Will. Yeah. Yeah. Look at that. Get somebody to hose me down with a fire hose. Are you giving me James Dean right now?
再说一次，这对我太合适了。这太搞笑了。威尔，你看起来总是像房间里着火了一样。是啊。是啊。看看那个。找个人拿消防水管把我冲洗一下。你现在是在模仿詹姆斯·迪恩吗？
Will? Yeah, there it is. Yeah. Only the high eyebrows, squinty eyes. Oh my God. You used to talk, Jason and I used to say that we'd go to like events and you'd see somebody doing that and the thing like in the, in the, you know, in the step and repeat, we'd be like, oh, look at this guy's got real smoke in the eyes.
威尔？对，就是这样。对。只有高高的眉毛，眯缝着眼。哦天哪。以前，杰森和我经常说，我们会去参加那种活动，然后你会看到有人在做那个动作，就像在那个，在那个，你知道的，在背景板前拍照时，我们会说：“哦，看这家伙，眼里真有烟雾效果。”
Yeah, it looks real confused. Yeah, look at that. That's sexy. That's what they like. Was your wife there giving you shit just off camera? Or was she, was she super supportive about it? She had a few jokes about it, but she was genuinely proud. And, you know, she ribs me plenty.
是的，看起来真的很困惑。是的，看那个。那才叫性感。这就是他们喜欢的。你妻子当时就在镜头外对你冷嘲热讽吗？还是说，她对此超级支持？她对此开了一些玩笑，但她是打心底里感到骄傲。而且，你知道的，她没少取笑我。
But I think she was genuinely proud. And like I said, you know, it gives the internet license to just, you know, take shots and tell you why, why, why you didn't deserve it. And so I just stayed off the internet for a few days. Not a boy. And it was a successful strategy. I didn't need to see all that. You frame this cover and I don't need confirmation on that.
但我认为她是打心底里骄傲的。就像我说的，你知道的，这让互联网有了借口，去，你知道的，冷嘲热讽，告诉你为什么，为什么，为什么你不配得到这个。所以我只是几天没上网。干得好，小子。这是一个成功的策略。我不需要看那些。你把这个封面装裱起来了，我不需要对此进行确认。
I know it's framed. Yeah, yeah. It's here in our office. So we have a bunch of magazine covers hanging up in the office. So it's kind of like our, our work hall of fame. We've got our Vanity Fair cover or Chrissy's Glamour cover and all of our cover. She has like 10 times more than me, but at least I have people sexist man. Which could be worth 10.
我知道它被装裱起来了。对，对。它就在我们的办公室里。所以我们的办公室里挂着一堆杂志封面。这有点像我们的工作名人堂。我们有我们的《名利场》封面，克里西的《魅力》封面，还有我们所有的封面。她拥有的数量大约是我的十倍，但至少我有《人物》的最性感男士。这也许能顶十个。
I think that's worth 10. John, back to like the, the, the, the music part and the, and the album. I know you collaborate with a bunch of people. Are there, are there people that you have yet to collaborate with that you've always dreamed of? Is there any kind of one or two top people at the, at the top of the list? Well, I love Kendrick Lamar. Two people who recently put out albums that I love Kendrick and Beyonce.
我觉得这能顶十0个。约翰，回到关于，那个，那个，音乐的部分和专辑。我知道你和很多人合作过。有没有哪位是你一直梦想合作，但至今还没合作过的？有没有一两个名列前茅的人选？我很喜欢肯德里克·拉马尔。最近推出专辑并深受我喜爱的两个人，肯德里克和碧昂斯。
So I would love to collaborate with both of them and put out great albums recently that I've been listening to. Yeah. Do you read reviews by the way of your albums or songs? Yeah, I do. Sometimes I don't read all of them, but I, I read a decent amount and you know, I'm always curious to see what people think about it. And sometimes I feel like sometimes I disagree with them,
所以我也非常乐意与他们俩合作。他们最近都推出了我一直在听的优秀专辑。是的。顺便问一下，你会看你的专辑或歌曲的乐评吗？会，我会看。有时我不会全看完，但我会看相当一部分，你知道的，我总是很好奇别人是怎么看的。有时我觉得，有时我会不同意他们的看法，
but sometimes I also feel like they don't get it. Like some like, cause I'll say things. It sounds like they just don't get it. They don't connect with the material and they don't understand what I was trying to do. But hey, it's always interesting to see what they say. And I don't let it get to me too much, but I'm always curious. So wait, speaking of things that have always gotten positive reviews, you got this gig on The Voice, which is like, first of all, how did you land the gig?
但有时我也觉得他们根本没get到。比如有些，因为我会说一些话。听起来他们就是没理解。他们没有和作品产生共鸣，也不懂我到底想表达什么。不过嘿，看看他们怎么说总是挺有趣的。我不会让这些影响我太多，但我总是很好奇。所以，说起那些一直获得正面评价的事物，你在《美国好声音》里得到了这份工作，首先，你是怎么得到这份工作的？
And tell me about some crazy, like the craziest auditions you've seen. Well, you know, The Voice is like a plum gig in our business because you get to, they keep you in LA, which if you live here and you have a family here, it's like an easy gig to have just drive up to Universal when you have to drive up there. And you get paid essentially like you would be on tour, but you're home and you get to use your kids. So it's, it's like really a good gig. And it's fun. You get to be around other musicians.
能跟我讲讲你见过的那些疯狂的，最疯狂的试镜吗？嗯，你知道的，《美国好声音》在我们这行里是个肥差，因为你能，他们让你留在洛杉矶，如果你住在这里，又在这里有家庭，这是一份很好办的工作，只要在需要的时候开车去环球影城就行。你的收入基本上和巡演差不多，但你人在家，还能顺便利用你的孩子。所以，这真的是一份很棒的工作。而且很有趣。你能和别的音乐人呆在一起。
You get to be inspiring all these younger artists. And it's truly a fun job. And I guested on the show. We have guest advisors on the show. I was on Adam's team helping advise his team and an opening came up and they, I think they liked when I was a guest advisor and offered me the job. And I did it for one season. They asked me back and now I've done seven seasons in a row.
你能激励所有这些年轻的艺术家。这真的是一份有趣的工作。我曾作为嘉宾参加过这个节目。我们在节目里有嘉宾导师。我曾在亚当的战队里帮忙指导他的战队，后来空出了一个位置，我觉得他们挺喜欢我当嘉宾导师时的表现，于是就把这份工作交给了我。我做了一季。他们邀请我回归，现在我已经连续做了七季了。
Wow. My seventh season in a row. And I don't see it stopping anytime soon. I really like doing it. I really enjoy it. I really enjoy working with the young artists. That's rewarding. And it's a fun show.
哇。我连续做的第七季。而且我看它短期内不会停下来。我真的很喜欢做这个。我真的很享受。我真的很喜欢和年轻艺术家合作。这很有意义。而且这是一个有趣的节目。
Yeah. It is great. You're great on it. What about producing television? Is that something that's interesting to you? Yeah. Well, that's how I got Miami from Jesus Christ Superstar. We were producers on that show and then I have a production company called Get Lifted Film Company.
是的。这真的很棒。你在节目里表现得很棒。制作电视节目呢？那也是你感兴趣的领域吗？对。这就是我如何从《万世巨星》中得到迈阿密的。我们是那个节目的制作人，然后我有一个制作公司叫“被推举电影公司”。
We've done documentaries. We've done television series. We did one called Underground, which was particularly good. And when we were really proud of it, it was about the Underground Railroad. We've done feature films. Our biggest film we did was also on Netflix called Jingle Jangle. It was a holiday film featuring our Forest Whitaker and Felicia Rashad and some others. And it was a Christmas musical basically about a toy maker, kind of a Willy Wonka type toy maker.
我们制作过纪录片。我们制作过电视剧。我们做过一部叫《地下铁路》的，特别棒。我们对此非常骄傲，讲的是地下铁路的故事。我们制作过故事片。我们制作的最大的电影也在网飞上播出，叫《圣诞Jingle Jangle》。这是一部假日电影，由福里斯特·惠特克、菲莉西亚·拉斯海德等人主演。这基本上是一部关于玩具匠的圣诞音乐剧，有点像威利·旺卡那种类型的玩具匠。
And yeah, we've done some really cool stuff. A lot of things that were music related, but some things that weren't as well. Have you scored films at all and would you want to? I've written songs for film, but I haven't actually scored a film. So I wrote Glory for Selma with Common. And then I've written a bunch of songs for other films too. And I wrote a song for that Jingle Jangle film that we did. And I'll be writing more film stuff and Broadway stuff in the future.
是的，我们做了一些非常酷的事情。很多都跟音乐有关，但也有一些无关的。你给电影配过乐吗？你想吗？我为电影写过歌，但我实际上没有给电影配过乐。所以我为电影《塞尔玛》和孔蒙合作创作了《荣耀》。后来我也为其他电影写过很多歌。我还为我们制作的《圣诞Jingle Jangle》电影写了一首歌。未来我还会创作更多电影和百老汇的作品。
So all of that is fun to me. I love writing and I love writing with an assignment too, I think. So that's why I like film and TV and Broadway because when you have some direction, it's kind of fun to have that assignment and some direction in your writing. What about when the kids start getting a little bit deeper roots into school and into their social rhythm and all that stuff? How do you think that's going to affect your ability to get out there on the road and tour a bunch? Are you going to homeschool them like you were and just take them out with you all the time?
所以所有这些对我都很有趣。我喜欢写作，而且我觉得我也喜欢带着任务去写作。这就是为什么我喜欢电影、电视和百老汇，因为当你有一些方向时，带着任务和一些方向去写作是一件很有趣的事。当孩子们开始对学校、他们的社交节奏以及所有这些事情有更深的根基时，你觉得这会如何影响你外出巡演和大量演出的能力？你会像以前那样在家自己教他们，然后一直把他们带在身边吗？
No, I don't think we'll homeschool them and we'll just kind of figure out the timing. I think there's a way to pace touring so it's not too imposing. Yeah, like the kids went with me on this summer tour. And like I said, I have the voice so it limits the amount of time I can tour, but it replaces touring with another gig that I really like. And so as long as I have that, then I won't have to tour as much. But once I start touring again more, I'll definitely pace it in a way that makes sense. I really enjoy being a dad and a husband and so I try to make time for that
不，我不认为我们会自己在家教他们，我们到时候会自己摸索时间。我觉得巡演是有办法调整节奏的，不会太强人所难。是的，就像孩子们这次夏天跟我去巡演一样。就像我说的，我有《美国好声音》，所以这限制了我的巡演时间，但它用另一份我很喜欢的差事代替了巡演。只要我有这个，我就不用巡演那么多了。但一旦我再次开始更多地巡演，我一定会以合理的方式调整节奏。我非常享受做爸爸和丈夫，所以我尽量为此腾出时间，
and don't let work overcome it too much. I love that. Every time I've seen you perform or in interviews, you're always so nice and genuine and like, you know, amenable. When do you hit people, John? What part of your day? That's what I want to know. I try to do it off camera. That's smart, man. Very smart.
别让工作完全占据了生活。我太喜欢这样了。每次我看你表演或在采访中，你总是那么好心、真诚，而且，你知道的，平易近人。约翰，你什么时候才会对人发火？一天当中的哪个时候？这就是我想知道的。我尽量在镜头外发火。真聪明，伙计。非常聪明。
Really smart. What pisses you off? Yeah, what do you hate? Oh, the things I get mad about, well, a lot of it, I'm very into politics so I get pissed off about politics a lot and I get very engaged when it comes to politics so I'm pretty passionate about that stuff. And when I see people who harm other people, especially people who have less and have less power and fewer resources,
真的很聪明。什么事会惹毛你？是的，你讨厌什么？哦，让我生气的那些事，嗯，很大一部分，我对政治很感兴趣，所以我经常被政治气得够呛，当涉及到政治时我会全身心投入，所以我对那些东西挺有激情的。当我看到有人伤害其他人，尤其是那些拥有的少、权力小、资源少的人时，
I hate when people abuse their power and honestly, that pisses me off. What's the craziest thing on your rider when you tour? I have nothing crazy on there. It's like simple stuff. Come on, come on. Now, John, have you ever, go ahead. Gif, Sean, is a purple M&M answer. I don't have an answer. I don't have a good one. We have snacks, we have salted roasted almonds.
我讨厌别人滥用职权，说实话，这真的惹毛了我。你巡演时随行清单上最疯狂的东西是什么？我上面没有什么疯狂的东西。都是些简单的东西。拜托，拜托。约翰，你有没有，说吧。吉夫，肖恩，是个紫色的M&M豆的答案。我没有答案。我没有一个好的答案。我们有零食，我们有盐烤杏仁。
I ate the same meal before every show. Which is rotisserie chicken and veggies. Roasted chicken, yeah. And veggies. I'm very boring. Jason's got gas x. Jason, what is it? Gas x? I have some antacids in there.
我每次演出前都吃同一顿饭。也就是烤鸡和蔬菜。烤鸡，对。还有蔬菜。我很无聊。杰森带了防胀气药。杰森，那是什么？防胀气药？我那里有些抗酸药。
Yeah, but I fry it up. I mean, I saute it. Now, would you ever, would you ever, I'm sure you've been asked this before. I apologize, I don't know the answer. Would you ever consider running for some sort of an office? I won't. I, you know, I get somebody, one of the neocards, what's his name? Bill Crystal tweeted that the other day.
对，但我把它煎一下。我是说，我把它炒一下。现在，你有没有，你有没有，我相信以前有人问过你这个问题。我很抱歉，我不知道答案。你有没有考虑过竞选某种公职？我不会。我，你知道的，我找了个人，那些新保守派之一，他叫什么来着？比尔·克里斯托前几天发推特这么说了。
And no, definitely not. I want to be a part of the forward party, which is what they're creating, which is Democrats and Republicans have come together to start this third party. And they just forward you things. They forward you emails with funny chain mail and jokes. Well, Sean loves an email. Listen, nobody loves an email. I was thinking about when you.
不，绝对不会。我想加入前进党，那是他们正在创立的党派，由民主党和共和党人联合起来成立的第三个党派。他们只是转发给你一些东西。他们给你转发带有搞笑连锁信和笑话的电子邮件。好吧，肖恩最喜欢电子邮件了。听着，没有人比肖恩更喜欢电子邮件了。我在想什么时候你。
Let's give Sean's email address right now. John, you were talking about your job. John, when you were talking about that job, when you were working consulting, I was thinking like, God, that seems like a nightmare. But Sean would love it because he loves getting emails and responding quickly. He loves forwards. Oh, he loves being in an office environment. He fucking, right?
现在就把肖恩的电子邮件地址公布出来吧。约翰，你刚才在谈论你的工作。约翰，当你谈到那份工作，当你从事咨询工作时，我在想，天哪，那听起来像个噩梦。但肖恩会喜欢，因为他喜欢收邮件并迅速回复。他喜欢转发。哦，他喜欢在办公室环境里工作。他妈的，对吧？
Sean, am I lying? I like, I like admin. I like admin. I love admin. He loves admin. Johnny Legend, we've taken. You sound like you'd make a good executive assistant. Yeah, I'm not about it.
肖恩，我在撒谎吗？我喜欢，我喜欢行政工作。我喜欢行政工作。我太爱行政工作了。他热爱行政工作。传奇约翰，我们占用了。你听起来很适合当行政助理。是的，我对那个不感兴趣。
We've taken way too much of your time. Thank you for being here. You are a nice man. John the legend. Thank you guys. Thanks for having me. Thank you, man. And the album is so good.
我们占用了你太多时间了。谢谢你来到这里。你是个好人。传奇约翰。谢谢你们。谢谢邀请我。谢谢你，伙计。那张专辑太棒了。
It's called legend. I can't wait for everybody to hear it. It's so, so good. Thank you. I appreciate it. Well, keep out it. Don't work too, too hard. And I think hashtag legend 2024.
它叫《传奇》。我迫不及待想让每个人都听到它。它真的，真的太棒了。谢谢。我很感激。好吧，继续加油。别工作得太，太辛苦了。我觉得话题标签是：传奇2024。
I think we've made it official. It's official. Yeah. Jason's looking for an outsider here. All right. Go get it. See you, man. All right, John.
我觉得我们把它定为官方标签了。这是官方的了。是的。杰森在这里找个局外人。好了。去吧。回见，伙计。好的，约翰。
Take care, everybody. Thank you very much. Take care, buddy. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. How about that guy? John Legend. Listen, this guy's a legend.
大家保重。非常感谢。保重，伙计。拜拜。拜拜。那家伙怎么样？传奇约翰。听着，这家伙是个传奇。
Okay. I mean, it's right there in the name. It's so smart to build it in your name. It's so smart. I forget to ask him. Do you think that's his real name? Like Alicia Keys? Is Alicia Keys and she plays piano?
好吧。我是说，名字里就写着呢。把这个写进你的名字里太聪明了。太聪明了。我忘了问他。你觉得那是他的真名吗？就像艾莉西亚·凯斯一样？艾莉西亚·凯斯会弹钢琴？
This is not. That's not his real name. You know what it is. That's hair style. Did you know that? No. No. Dude, his real name is John Baxter.
这不是。那不是他的真名。你知道那是什么吗？那是发型。你知道吗？不。不。老兄，他的真名是约翰·巴克特。
Is that true? No, Sean. Fuck. I believed you. I know you did, ain't you? John Baxter. Just lay down. Just elevate your feet above your heart.
真的吗？不，肖恩。操。我居然信了。我知道你信了，对吧？约翰·巴克特。躺下吧。把你的脚抬高过心脏。
Yeah. No. You guys, check out his album if you can. I totally will. I can't believe it. He's just one of those guys. Like he's doing everything. He's doing everything.
是的。不。伙计们，如果可以的话去听听他的专辑。我绝对会去听。我简直不敢相信。他就是那种人。他什么都做。他什么都做。
He's doing everything. He's doing everything. He's doing everything. He's doing everything. He's doing all those guys. Like everything he's talking about, again, just so busy and prolific and just doing stuff and putting out records and doing the show and doing this. And I'm like, I'm so tired listening to him.
他什么都做。他什么都做。他什么都做。他什么都做。他什么都做。就像他谈到的一切，还是那句话，太忙碌、太高产了，就是一直在做事，出唱片，做节目，搞这个。我就觉得，听着他我都觉得累。
I'm like, how do you do it? I know. He's a young man. He's a young man. I ran into him at Sundance, the Sundance Film Festival years ago. And he's like, hey, you have a production company. How did you do that? And I was like, let me just start one, right?
我就想，你是怎么做到的？我懂。他是个年轻人。他是个年轻人。几年前我在圣丹斯，圣丹斯电影节上碰过他。他说：“嘿，你有一家制作公司。你是怎么做到的？”我就说：“那就开一家呗，对吧？”
And we were talking so many years ago and here he is. And he was like, cool, and then he went and did it and started and has all these shows and stuff. Yeah. And now I'm telling you, how did you do that? Exactly. By the way, it's the best idea, right? I mean, to just do that, to be curious like that, and go, hey, you, you did something
我们很多年前就在聊这个，而他现在就在这儿。他当时说：“酷”，然后他就去干了，把公司办起来，还有了所有这些节目之类的。对。现在反过来我在对你说：“你是怎么做到的？”没错。顺便说一句，这是个绝妙的主意，对吧？我是说，就这样做，保持这种好奇心，然后说：“嘿，你，你做了一件
that I think that I want to do. How did you do that? How did you do that? Right. I love that. I love that. Which is better than, is better than like what you do, Will, which is you're just, bye, curious.
我觉得我想做的事。你是怎么做到的？你是怎么做到的？”对吧。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。这可比，比你做的事要好，威尔，也就是你，拜拜，好奇。
Oh my God. We got it so fast. Bye, curious. We used the same one over and over. We got to get to the ads. Let's get to the ads because I got a hard out. Let's go. I just loved that from the sidelines.
哦天哪。我们接得太快了。拜拜，好奇。我们把同一个梗用了一遍又一遍。我们得播广告了。我们插播广告吧，因为我时间很紧，得走了。走吧。我太喜欢刚才在场边说的那些了。
That was so lame. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjalf, Bennett Barbacow and Michael Grant Terry. Smart Lost. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太逊了。Smart。Smart。SmartLess是100%有机且由罗布·阿姆贾尔夫、贝内特·巴巴库和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作的。Smart Lost。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。